This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. One summer day in 1972 when David Daniels was a kid, he found himself out in the front yard of his family's home. I was at the apartment, just sitting and enjoying the afternoon. For once in my life I wasn't doing anything. David was 9 years old and living in the suburbs just outside of LA. That's producer Christopher Johnson. As David sat in the grass taking in that calli sunshine, he was pretty sure he was alone. And then on the other side of a big creaky gate nearby, he heard footsteps.
这里是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1972年夏天的一个日子，当时大卫·丹尼尔斯还是个孩子，他发现自己站在自家房子前院的草坪上。我在公寓里，只是坐着享受下午的时光。我这辈子破天荒地什么也没做。大卫当时9岁，住在洛杉矶郊外。那是制作人克里斯托弗·约翰逊。当大卫坐在草地上享受加州的阳光时，他确信自己是独自一人。接着，在附近一扇吱吱作响的大门另一边，他听到了脚步声。
And all of a sudden, the door swang open. David looked up to find a grown man, a total stranger now standing in the front swaying open. Hmm? KUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUKUK and he said, want to read a comic? And I said, yeah. So he hands David this little comic book about the size of your average cell phone. And it says, this was your life on the cover and it has like a movie screen. And there's an angel and an naked guy staring at the screen. Like, this was your life.
突然间，门猛地被推开了。大卫抬起头，发现一个成年男子，一个完全的陌生人，正站在前面，门还在晃悠。嗯？哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈……他说：“想看漫画吗？”我说：“想。”于是他递给大卫一本小漫画书，大约普通手机那么大。封面上写着《这就是你的一生》，上面还有一个电影屏幕。屏幕上有一个天使和一个赤身裸体的男人正盯着屏幕，就像在说“这就是你的一生”。
And he said, you wanna read it to me? Okay. I mean, it's a comic. I've always loved comics. I'm addicted to comics. Inside, David found a 21-page story, illustrated in simple black ink. It begins with a dopey guy wearing a cardigan and a turtleneck standing next to his flashy Corvette.
他说：“你想读给我听吗？”好吧。我的意思是，这是一本漫画。我一直很喜欢漫画。我对漫画上瘾了。翻开封面，大卫发现了一个21页的故事，用简单的黑色墨水绘制。故事开头是一个穿着羊毛衫和高领毛衣的呆头呆脑的家伙，正站在他那辆拉风的克尔维特跑车旁边。
He's looking all smug, smoking a pipe and sipping a cocktail. Life is good. Then immediately it's the grim reaper with a sideness hand and he's he's got this black cloak on and it's like, oh, dude, the grim reaper sneaks up on this guy and he hits him in the back and he guys grabbing his heart and he says, whoah, and his drink falls out and his pipe falls out. And that's like not what I expected. I'm caught. I'm totally caught. I gotta know what's happening next.
他看起来得意洋洋地抽着烟斗，啜饮着鸡尾酒。生活真美好。紧接着，死神拿着一把镰刀出现了，他穿着黑色的斗篷，仿佛在说：“哦，伙计，死神悄悄接近了这个家伙，从背后袭击了他。”那家伙捂着心脏说：“哇，”他的饮料掉了下来，烟斗也掉了下来。这完全出乎我的意料。我被吸引住了。我完全被吸引住了。我必须知道接下来会发生什么。
In some ways, all this looked familiar to a comic book fan like David. You had the weird characters with the goofy over-the-top expressions and those stylized speech bubbles. But when he looked closer, David saw something that made this comic book totally distinct from the superhero fare that he was used to, because it was full of Bible verses. This stranger had given little David
在某种程度上，这一切对大卫这样的漫画迷来说很熟悉。这里有古怪的角色、夸张滑稽的表情，还有那些风格化的对话气泡。但当他仔细看时，大卫发现了一些让这本漫画与他习惯的超级英雄漫画完全不同的东西，因为里面充满了圣经经文。这个陌生人给小大卫
something called a chick tract. A tract is a common name for a pamphlet with religious messages, and chick tracks were Christian comic books that fit in the palm of your hand. And immediately the guy falls down the pipes in the air, the glasses in the air, and he falls to the ground. They were at the funeral. He was a good man.
送去了一种叫做“小册子”（Chick tract）的东西。小册子是带有宗教信息的传单的常见名称，而这类小册子则是能放在手掌心的基督教漫画书。紧接着，那家伙连烟斗带眼镜一起掉在空中，然后摔倒在地上。他们正在参加葬礼。他是个好人。
And I love that. The check track that David was reading was about a man who dies suddenly and is whisked out of his grave in up to heaven by an arc angel with a fresh blow dry and ginormous wings who streaks through the sky like Superman. In the track, the undead man stands in front of a colossal faceless god on a throne while they watch the guy's entire sinful life and playback like some drive-in movie. from Drive in Movie. God's deciding if this guy stays in heaven
我很喜欢这一点。大卫正在读的这本小册子讲述了一个人突然死去，并被一位拥有清爽发型和巨型翅膀的大天使从坟墓里带到天堂的故事，大天使像超人一样在天空中飞驰。在这本小册子里，这个死而复生的男人站在王座上一个巨大的、没有面孔的上帝面前，同时他们看着这个家伙充满罪恶的一生像露天电影一样回放。从露天电影。上帝在决定这家伙是留在天堂
or burns forever in hell. And if all this stuff wasn't heavy enough for a nine-year-old, at the end of the tract, like every check-tracked, there was a prayer, the stranger asked David to keep reading. And then he said,
还是在烈火中永生燃烧。如果所有这些对于一个九岁的小孩来说还不够沉重的话，在小册子的结尾，就像每一本小册子一样，有一个祈祷，陌生人请大卫继续往下读。然后他说：
would you like to pray to receive Jesus as your savior? And I said, yeah. So then we went on page 23 and we read what it says. Trust Jesus today and I went through and I prayed and thought about everything I was reading and prayed it from my heart. And he said, you're a Christian. He led David Keith, that small black and white comic book, told him to find a really good church, and then he just bounced. He walked right back into the alley and out of my life, and I never saw him again. That whole exchange only lasted a few minutes, but it changed David's life.
“你想祈祷接受耶稣作为你的救主吗？”我说：“想。”于是我们翻到第23页，读了上面的话：“今天信任耶稣。”我通读了一遍，为我所读的一切进行了祈祷，并由衷地做出了祷告。他说：“你是个基督徒了。”他引导了大卫·基特，那本黑色的小漫画书，告诉他去找一个真正好的教堂，然后他就离开了。他径直走回小巷，消失在我的生命中，我再也没见过他。整个过程只持续了几分钟，但它改变了大卫的生活。
And after that, I would go on my skateboard or my bicycle all the way from the other side of town, all the way over to Christian life bookstore and pay my nickel and every time they came out with a new one I'd come and get it. I wanted them all. Gotta get them all. I wanted them very much and whenever somebody had one that I didn't have I always wanted that one too. David is still a Christian today.
在那之后，我会踩着滑板或自行车，从镇子的另一头一直骑到“基督教生活书店”，花上五个镍币。每当他们推出新书时，我都会去拿。我想要所有的。必须把它们全收集齐。我非常想要它们，每当有人有一本我没有的书时，我也总是想要那一本。大卫至今仍是一名基督徒。
He's one accountless people all over the world who have been impacted one way or another by a Chick-Track. When I was growing up in the 80s, Chick-Tracks were everywhere. You find them in movie theaters and bus station bathrooms on subways and all over shopping malls. People would slip them inside VHS rentals or library books. Since Chick-Publication started in the mid 1960s it has sold more than 1 billion tracks. There are 270 different chick tracks, with titles like The Death Cookie, Kidnapped, Mean Mama, The Sissy, and Satan Comes to Salem. Many of these are black and white Christian horror stories that pull from a huge cast of characters, witches, bikers, Hindus, rock
他是世界各地数以百万计因“小册子”而受到某种影响的人之一。当我在80年代长大时，“小册子”随处可见。你在电影院、汽车站洗手间、地铁以及各大购物中心都能找到它们。人们会把它们塞进VHS录像带租赁店或图书馆的书里。自20世纪60年代中期推出以来，“小册子”已售出超过10亿册。共有270种不同的小册子，书名包括《死亡饼干》、《绑架》、《吝啬妈妈》、《娘娘腔》和《撒旦来到塞勒姆》。其中许多是黑色的基督教恐怖故事，取材于庞大的角色阵容：女巫、飞车党、印度教徒、摇滚
and rollers, Catholics, queer people, truckers, masons, and trick-or-treaters. And at some point in the tract, the protagonist often has to make a choice, either except Jesus as their savior or get tossed like cordwood into a lake of fire. These little Christian comics have left a really complicated legacy. Collectors are mesmerized by their edginess and catch. The Smithsonian regards chick tracks as American religious artifacts and keeps a bunch of them in its vaults. At the same time, many of these comics are filled with some ugly and dangerous messages,
乐手、天主教徒、酷儿群体、卡车司机、共济会成员以及不给糖就捣蛋的人。在小册子的某个时刻，主角通常必须做出选择：要么接受耶稣为救主，要么像木柴一样被扔进火湖里。这些小小的基督教漫画留下了非常复杂的遗产。收藏家们为其前卫和震撼力所着迷。史密森尼学会将这些小册子视为美国宗教文物，并在其金库中保存了许多。与此同时，其中许多漫画充满了丑陋和危险的信息，
including homophobia and Islamophobia. So the same tracks that have been hoarded and preserved have also been boycotted and banned and condemned as hate speech. So what is it about these tiny inflammatory comic books that has allowed them to not just survive, but spread across the planet for the past six decades? The answer lies in the rise of the larger than life artist behind the tracks. Greetings in the precious name of our Lord Jesus Christ.
包括恐同症和仇视伊斯兰教。因此，那些被囤积和保存下来的小册子，同时也遭到抵制、禁售并被谴责为仇恨言论。那么，这些微小而煽动性的漫画书究竟有什么魔力，让它们在过去六十年里不仅得以生存，还传遍了整个星球？答案在于幕后那位富有传奇色彩的艺术家。奉我们主耶稣基督宝贵的圣名向您问好。
This is Jack Chick's Beacon. Before we go into this, the voice you're hearing is Jack T. Chick, head of Chick Publications and the creator of Chick Tracks. Jack died in 2016, but in life he was the man responsible for some of the most influential and most infamous Christian lit of the 20th century. As believers in Christ, we have great authority over the powers of darkness given to us by Jesus, because we are his ambassadors and joint heirs with Christ. Jack Chick didn't actually grow up in the church. The story of his conversion begins when he's well into his 20s.
这里是杰克·奇克的灯塔。在我们深入探讨之前，你听到的声音正是杰克·T·奇克本人，他是“奇克出版公司”的负责人兼“小册子”的创作者。杰克于2016年去世，但在生前，他负责创作了20世纪最具影响力也最声名狼藉的一些基督教文学作品。作为基督里的信徒，我们对黑暗势力拥有耶稣赐予的极大权柄，因为我们是他的大使，与基督同作后嗣。杰克·奇克其实并非在教会长大。他信主的奇妙故事始于他二十多岁的时候。
He was a World War II vet who just returned from fighting in the Pacific. It was fit and confident and good looking, with his thick, dark hair and all American jawline. Jack was also crazy in love with his sweetheart, Lola Lynn Prittle. They'd met at the Pasadena Playhouse, where Jack had a two-year scholarship to study acting. Together, they dreamed of being movie stars. J. Jack and Lola Lynn got married in 1948. What happened next would become foundational to Jack Chick's almost mythic origin story. When he goes with his wife on their honeymoon,
他是刚从太平洋战场归来的二战老兵。他身材健美、自信、英俊，有着浓密的黑发和典型的美国人下巴。杰克还疯狂地爱着他的甜心罗拉·琳·普里特尔。他们在帕萨迪纳剧 Playhouse 相遇，杰克当时在那里获得了两年的表演奖学金。他们共同梦想着成为电影明星。杰克和罗拉·琳于1948年结婚。接下来发生的事情，将成为杰克·奇克近乎神话般的起源故事的基础。当他和妻子去度蜜月时，
he meets the parents. And the mother is said to have, according to Jack Chick, pulled her daughter aside after meeting Jack Chick and said, what is this thing that you brought home to us? They were not impressed with him at all. Hahaha. Kurt Kirstiner is an expert on Jack Chick and Chick Tracks.
他去见了岳父母。据说岳母在见到杰克·奇克后，把女儿拉到一边说：“你到底带了个什么东西回家给我们？”他们对他的印象一点也不好。哈哈哈哈。库尔特·柯斯蒂纳是研究杰克·奇克和小册子的专家。
He says things didn't get off to the best start when Jack went up to meet his new in-laws in Canada. LoLas parents were super religious and very conservative. To Mr. and Mrs. Prittle, Jack was bad news. He was no saint before he was drafted, but while Jack was overseas, he picked up smoking and up body mouth. I think it was his language and, you know, a rudeness and probably he was pretty cocky too.
他说，当杰克去加拿大拜访新岳父母时，事情并没有一个良好的开端。罗拉的父母非常虔诚且极为保守。在普里特尔夫妇眼里，杰克是个大麻烦。他在应征入伍前也不是什么圣人，但在海外服役期间，杰克染上了吸烟和说脏话的习惯。我认为是他的语言，你知道，还有粗鲁，而且可能他也非常傲慢。
You know, he just gone off and won a war and graduated the Pasadena Playhouse. He's about to become a famous actor. So, you know, he had everything going for him. Maybe, but Mrs. Prado was not impressed, and she was going to do something about the problem of Jack. She took him into another room and sat him down in front of the big family radio, and collected on. Friends in radio lounge are listening to the old-fashioned revival hour and international broadcasts of the gospel.
你知道，他刚刚去赢得了一场战争，并从帕萨迪纳剧院毕业。他即将成为一名著名的演员。所以，你知道，他可以说是占尽天时地利。也许吧，但普里特夫人对他毫无好感，她打算着手解决杰克这个“问题”。她把他带到另一个房间，让他坐在大家庭的收音机前，并打开了开关。收音机休息室的朋友们正在收听老式复兴时间和福音的国际广播。
And together they listened to a Christian show called The Old Fashioned Revival Hour, one of the most popular programs on the air in North America in the late 1940s. The host was a preacher named Charles Fuller. You that are alone in your home. Find someone else that spiritually minded and wear two or three or gather together in God's name. He says, ask whatsoever he will and shall be done." In Fuller's sermon, he talked about the Christian belief that everyone is sinful, and that Jesus died so that each human being, all those sinners, even the smoking, swearing jack chick, could spend their afterlives in heaven and not eternal hell. The way jack tells it, as the preacher
他们一起收听了一个名为《老式复兴时间》的基督教节目，这是20世纪40年代末北美最受欢迎的节目之一。主持人是一位名叫查尔斯·富勒的传教士。你们这些独自在家的人。找一个同样具有属灵思想的人，或者两三个人奉上帝的名聚在一起。他说：“你们若奉我的名求什么，我必成就。”在富勒的布道中，他谈到了基督教的信仰：每个人都是有罪的，而耶稣的死是为了让每一个人——所有那些罪人，甚至包括抽烟、说脏话的杰克·奇克——都能在天堂度过来世，而不是在地狱里永生。据杰克回忆，随着传教士的讲述，
spoke, he leaned in. It was a pretty basic Christian message, but he says it rocked his world. It had a big impact on him. And according to him, you know, he got down on his hands and knees and accepted Christ at that time. In the decade that followed, Jack's conversion would inspire him to change nearly everything about his life. One of the first things he did when he got back to Southern California was rethink his dreams of becoming a movie star.
他倾听了进去。这是一个非常基础的基督教信息，但他说这震撼了他的世界。这对他的影响很大。据他回忆，当时他跪在地上，接受了基督。在随后的十年里，杰克的皈依激励他改变了生活中的几乎一切。他回到南加州后做的第一件事，就是重新思考自己成为电影明星的梦想。
As far as Jack was concerned, the Hollywood lifestyle was totally incompatible with his new faith. So he just walked away. So instead of Hollywood, he returned to an interest he'd always had since he was a kid. This is Dan Rayburn who wrote a book about Jack Chick. I think it's the dream most young man of his generation had. And that was comics, drawing, visual art. As an adult, his art skills were okay, good enough to land a regular day job doing ads
在杰克看来，好莱坞的生活方式与他的新信仰完全不相容。所以他直接放弃了。因此，他没有选择好莱坞，而是回到了他从小就一直热衷的兴趣上。这是为杰克·奇克写过书的丹·雷伯恩。我认为这是他那个时代大多数年轻人的梦想。那就是漫画、绘画、视觉艺术。作为一个成年人，他的绘画技巧还算可以，足以在洛杉矶蓬勃发展的航空航天工业中找到一份做广告和技术插图的日常工作。杰克还有几个艺术方面的副业。在夜晚和周末，他为当地报纸画观点漫画和社论漫画。此外，他还有一个真正试图起步的连环漫画。这是一个类似《摩登原始人》的史前尼安德特人家庭的连环漫画，名为《时代变了吗？问号》，里面有穴居人和穴居女的卡通画，他们穿着兽皮，男人们扛着棍棒。这些是非常直观的主流连环画，他只是想像查尔斯·舒尔茨创作《花生漫画》那样打入连环画领域。他想成为一名主流漫画家。
and technical illustrations in LA's booming aerospace industry. Jack also had a couple of artistic side hustles. On nights and weekends, he did opinion and editorial cartoons for local newspapers. Plus, he had a comic strip that he was really trying to get off the ground. It was a Flintstone type comic strip about a prehistoric Neanderthal family called times have changed question mark and their cartoon drawings of cavemen and cave women where they wear animal skins and the men carry clubs. They were very straightforward mainstream strips where he was just trying to break into the strips the way Charles Shulls did with peanuts. He wanted to be a mainstream cartoonist.
随着杰克艺术生涯的发展，他对信仰的理解也越来越深。他加入了一家当地教会，并开始定期做礼拜。大约在1960年左右，杰克的一位同事，同为基督徒的同事，给了杰克一本看起来毫不起眼的书。这本书叫《从天而降的大能》，作者是查尔斯·芬尼，
As Jack was developing his art career, he was also growing deeper and deeper in his faith. He joined a local church and he started attending regularly. And then sometime around 1960, one of Jack's co-workers, a fellow Christian, gave Jack what seemed like a pretty unassuming book. It was called Power from On High, and it was written by a man named Charles Finney,
他是一位19世纪的牧师，也是一位伟大的基督教改革家。芬尼写道，教会领袖正在使整个宗教体验变得死气沉沉、索然无味。他认为，作为一个基督徒应该是令人兴奋和振奋的，去教会应该是一种充满力量的体验。但自满的教会领袖及其会众正在榨取本可以成为丰富基督徒生活的能量。那本书让杰克以崭新的眼光审视自己的教会，他对眼前的景象很不满意。他觉得
a 19th century minister who was a huge Christian reformer. Finney wrote that church leaders were making the whole religious experience lifeless and flat. He argued that being a Christian was supposed to be exciting and invigorating, going to church should be a powerful experience. But complacent church leaders and their congregations were sucking the energy out of what could otherwise be a rich Christian life. That book got Jack looking at his own church with fresh eyes and he was not happy with what he saw. He felt like
我一直在去教会，但里面全是一帮伪君子。他们更关心建造教堂，而不是关心建造教堂里的人。你知道，他们想要更多的建筑。他们不想要更多的人。他们想要更多的钱，但他们不想要更多的灵魂。杰克觉得，虽然他对祈祷、虔诚以及成为一个铁杆基督徒所需的一切都极其认真，但他的教友们却只是在模仿宗教生活。
I've been going to church but it's's just full of a bunch of phonies. And they're more concerned about building the church than they are about building the people in the church. You know, they want more buildings. They don't want more people. They want more money, but they don't want more souls. Jack felt that while he was super serious about prayer, devotion, and everything it took to be a hardcore Christian, his fellow parishioners were just pantomime in the religious life.
他视许多人为伪君子，他们嘴上说得好听，过的却是毫无神圣的生活。最糟糕的是，他们的虚伪正在拖垮整个教会，剥夺了基督徒所称的“复兴”那种神圣的能量和活力。对杰克来说，这是一场四级警报的精神紧急状态。他读过芬尼的书，那家伙点燃了火花。那是他的术语，点燃火花。再次请出大卫·尼尔斯。就是那个在20世纪70年代还是个九岁小孩时被小册子感化的人。
He saw many of them as hypocrites who talked a good talk while living ungodly lives. Worst of all, their hypocrisy was dragging the whole church down, robbing it of the kind of sacred energy and vitality that Christians call revival. And for Jack, this was a four alarm spiritual emergency. He had read Phine, and that guy is sparkler lit. That's his term, getting a sparkler lit. Here's David Daniels again. He's the one who was converted by a Chick-Track back in the 1970s when he was a nine-year-old.
大卫后来为杰克工作，两人成了朋友。他甚至还为杰克写了传记。他萌生了利用自己标志性艺术的想法，并且现在他为此找到了一个目的。这不仅仅是为了娱乐。而是要指出，如果世界上有什么需要改变的话。杰克想要唤醒沉睡中的教会，他觉得自己知道该怎么做。于是他拿着一支笔和一个速写本，以芬尼的著作作为文本，开始制作他自己的插图福音小册子。他创作的第一本小册子是关于那些并没有真正充满圣灵的教会的尖锐小册子，名为《葡萄酒复兴》。这本小册子的大小大致和典型的漫画书相当，杰克在书中基本上把
David later went on to work for Jack, and they became friends. He even wrote Jack's biography. And he got the idea of using his characteristic art and he now has a purpose for it. It's not just to entertain. It's to point out that if something needs to change in the world. Jack wanted to shake his church out of its stupor and he thought he knew how. So he sat down with a pen and a sketchbook and using Finney's writings as text, he began to make his own illustrated gospel tracks. Now the very first track he did was this rather scathing track about churches that were not really filled with the Holy Spirit and was called Wino Revival. The track was roughly the size of a typical comic book, and in it Jack basically dragged
他的整个教会痛骂了一顿，指责他们是一群懒惰自私的伪君子。他把他们描绘成看花花公子杂志、听摇滚乐的背道者，他们对主日学派对的兴趣远大于真正赞美至高者。《葡萄酒复兴》是一部严厉的漫画批判，由于他把教友们的面孔用作漫画角色，因而显得更加恶毒。他用了自己教会的成员。这让他们非常沮丧。这确实让他在自己的教会里陷入了困境，因为他在里面用了真人肖像。他们对此并不感激。
his whole church for being a bunch of lazy and selfish hypocrites. He depicted them as playboy reading, rock and roll listening backsliders who were more interested in their Sunday school parties than truly praising the most high. Why no revival is a harsh comic critique that's even more vicious because he used the faces of his fellow parishioners for the comics characters. He used members of his church. And they got them very upset. It did get him in the hot water at his own church because he used real people's likenesses in there. And they didn't appreciate it.
杰克最终退出了那个教会，但他在老会众身上看到了漫画如何能吸引人们的注意力并掀起波澜，他决定将这个概念发扬光大。他要用漫画向全世界的非基督徒传播救赎的信息，他从一些绝对世俗的事物中得到了指导。有一位牧师给他带来了这本书，这些漫画小册子，毛泽东委托出版的中国共产主义漫画书。那位牧师向杰克展示了半打钱包大小的漫画书，那是他从共产主义中国
Jack ended up quitting that church, but he saw in his old congregation how a comic could grab people's attention and stir things up, and he decided to take that concept and go way bigger with it. He was going to use comics to reach non-Christians everywhere, with a message of salvation, and he got guidance from something that was decidedly secular. There's a minister who brought him this book, these comic booklets, Chinese Communist comic books that Mao commissioned. That minister showed Jack a half dozen wallet-sized comic books that he'd brought back from a mission
传教回来后带回来的。它们只是小巧的长方形宣传册，基本上是在宣传共产主义。我认为人们刚刚意识到小漫画书是传播宣传的绝佳媒介。政府用它们向公民，尤其是孩子们普及社会主义常识。奇克明确表示，他的创意正是来源于这些毛泽东主义革命漫画，并且他要用“魔鬼的媒介来对抗魔鬼”。大约在1962年，杰克开始着手创作
trip to Communist China. They're just small, rectangular, propaganda booklets, and they're basically advocating communism. I think people just realized that small, comic booklets were a great medium for spreading propaganda. The government was using them to teach socialism 101 to its citizens, especially kids. And Chik specifically said that's where he got the idea, was from these Maoist revolutionary comics, and that he was gonna use the devil's medium to fight the devil. Around 1962, Jack got to work creating
他自己的宣传小册子，但杰克的漫画不是为了让孩子们皈依社会主义，而是旨在让罪人皈依奉献给基督的生活。当杰克最初拥抱他的信仰时，他并不仅仅是成为了一个普通的基督徒。他成为了一名福音派基督徒，而福音派的一个核心信条就是传福音，传播信仰并赢得归信者。杰克把自己视为圣战中的一名士兵，他的动力来自于他对某种事物的憎恶。
his own propaganda booklets, but instead of converting kids to socialism, Jack's comics aimed to convert sinners to a life dedicated to Christ. When Jack first embraced his faith, he didn't just become any Christian. He became an evangelical, and one key tenet of evangelicalism is to evangelize, to spread the faith and win converts. Jack saw himself as a soldier in a holy war, and he was motivated by his hatred of what
我姑且称之为60年代。我认为奇克基本上把自己理解为置于这样一种近乎神话般的叙事中，其中邪恶势力在密谋。研究宗教的杰森·比文斯说，对杰克和他的福音派同僚来说，20世纪60年代的社会变革本质上就是一场宣战。杰克看到的邪恶势力
I'm just going to call the 60s. I see Chick as basically understanding himself as situated in this almost mythic narrative where the forces of evil have conspired. Jason Bivens, who teaches religious study, says that for Jack and his fellow evangelicals, the social changes of the 1960s were essentially a declaration of war. The forces of evil that Jack saw
在周围密谋的，按特定顺序排列，是：同性恋者的平等权利、性解放、所谓的离婚革命，以及最高法院对公立学校强制祈祷和读经的禁令。显然，这是一个被美国及其发展状况天天折磨的人。因此，如果各大机构没有受到同样的震撼，这对他来说立刻就会被判定为一个问题。杰克的目的是打破这种局面。和许多福音派一样，他把自己定位为被流放的外来者，别无选择
conspiring all around him were, in no particular order, equal rights for gay people, sexual liberation, the so-called divorce revolution, and the Supreme Court's ban on mandatory prayer and Bible reading in public schools. Clearly, this is a guy who himself is being rattled daily by America and how America is developing. And so if institutions are not similarly rattled, that's going to immediately code as a problem to him. Jack's aim was to rattle the cage. Like many evangelicals, he positioned himself as an embezzled outsider who had no choice
只能在精神上拿起武器去战斗。杰克的打击目标包括任何与巫术或神秘学相关的东西。他把这一切都看作是撒旦阴谋的一部分，旨在诱惑人们离开基督并堕入地狱。你会看到这样的小册子：龙与地下城是如何把你引向地狱的。你知道，不仅仅是地狱，在最后一格被扔进火湖之前，你会被恶魔或女巫以极其残暴血腥的方式谋杀。杰克盯上了通灵板、女巫、重金属、撒旦，当然还有万圣节。这家伙恨透了万圣节。你只会看到这样的描述：一个连环杀手在你讨糖时绑架了你，或者仅仅因为参加
but to spiritually take up arms and fight. Jack Stargates included anything he associated with sorcery or the occult. He saw it all as part of Satan's plot to lure people away from Christ and into hell. You'd see it tracked about how dungeons and dragons will lead you to hell. You know, not just hell, but you'll be murdered brutally murdered by a demon or a witch in violent, gory detail before you're then cast into the lake of fire in the last panel. Jack came for Ouija boards, witches, heavy metal, Satan, obviously, even Halloween. That dude hated Halloween. You just get these depictions of, you know, a mass murderer abducting you while you're trick-or-treating or being, you know, secretly abducted into a satanic group simply by attending
了一场摇滚乐演唱会就被秘密绑架进一个邪教组织，诸如此类。这类小册子听起来可能很荒谬，好像杰克只是讨厌乐趣。但他也创作过更黑暗、更丑陋、坦率说也很危险的漫画。他将穆斯林描绘成天生暴力、执着于接管美国的恶魔崇拜者。有数十本小册子攻击伊斯兰教、印度教以及杰克贴上“虚假宗教”标签的其他信仰。杰克的另一个持续攻击目标是同性恋。
a rock concert, this kind of stuff. Those sorts of tracks might sound ridiculous, like Jack just kind of hated fun. But he's also made comics that are much darker, uglier, and honestly dangerous. He depicts Muslims as demon worshipers who are inherently violent and bent on taking over America. There are more than three dozen chick-tracks attacking Islam, Hinduism, and other faiths that Jack has labeled false religions. Another of Jack's consistent targets was homosexuality.
在他最著名的一本小册子中，杰克严厉抨击了所多玛和蛾摩拉的故事。在另一本坦率地说令人毛骨悚然的小册子中，他将同性恋描绘成童年强奸的产物，以及一些福音派喜欢称之为“同性恋议程”的东西。几十年来，杰克一直受到严厉批评，这是理所应当的，因为他是仇恨文学的贩卖者。每当他受到攻击时，他都会认为这听起来像是撒旦启发的声音。他在与我作战，这就是它正在起作用的证据。
In one of his most famous tracks, Jack goes hard on the Sodom and Gomorrah story. In another, frankly, horrifying, chick-tracked, he portrays homosexuality as a product of childhood rape and what some evangelicals like to call the gay agenda. Over the decades, Jack has been heavily criticized and rightly, as a purveyor of hate literature. And whenever he gets attacked, he looks at that as, that sounds like something that, you know, the spin inspired by Satan. He's at war with me, and this is proof that it's working.
这种对抗性的、指着鼻子挑起争端的能量，自20世纪60年代初杰克·奇克坐下来创作福音小册子那一刻起就一直驱动着他。在接下来的几年里，杰克把所有的空闲时间都狂热地投入到这些漫画的创作中。他制作插图版面，将其印刷出来，然后在厨房里将这些页面装订成8到10英寸的小册子，大小和普通漫画书差不多。到20世纪60年代初，奇克夫妇把他们的家变成了一种生产中心……页面装订成8到10英寸的小册子，大小和普通漫画书差不多。
This kind of confrontational finger in your face, fight picking energy, drove Jack Chick from the moment that he sat down to create his gospel tracks in the early 1960s. And for the next few years, Jack spent every second of his free time working feverishly on those comics. He would make his illustrated panels, get them printed, and then write in his kitchen, he assembled the pages into eight to ten-inch booklets about the same size as typical comic books. By the early 1960s, the chicks had turned their home into a kind of production pages into eight to ten-inch booklets about the same size as typical comic books.
到20世纪60年代初，奇克夫妇把他们的家变成了一种生产中心，杰克在那里写作和绘画。他坐在厨房的桌子旁。他第一次为自己创作作品。面对未知的读者群，他不是在迎合辛迪加。他不是在为航空航天业的老板画画。在我看来，这是他画过的最好的作品之一。那是因为对地狱的描绘太精彩了。
By the early 1960s, the chicks that turned their home into a kind of production center, where Jack would write and draw. He's sitting at his kitchen table. He's working on his own work for the first time. With an unknown audience, he's not targeting the syndicates. He's not drawing for his boss in the aerospace industry. And in my opinion, it's some of the best work he ever did. That's because depictions of hell are fantastic.
而且非常详细。它展示了线条的数量，仅仅是页面上的交叉阴影和钢笔痕迹的数量。这不是仓促赶工的作品。页面上的交叉阴影和钢笔痕迹的数量。这不是仓促赶工的作品。大约在杰克发展成为漫画家的同时，诸如《来自地窖的故事》和《地狱宝库》之类的恐怖漫画变得超级受欢迎。尽管杰克从未承认这一点，但丹·雷伯恩确信这些恐怖
And they're very detailed. It shows the quantity of the line work, just the amount of cross-atching and pen marks on the page. It was not a rush job. of cross-adging and pen marks on the page. It was not a rushed job. Around the same time that Jack had been developing as a comic artist, horror comics like Tales from the Crypt and The Vault of Horror had become super popular. And even though Jack never acknowledged it, Dan Rayburn is convinced that those horror
漫画对杰克的视觉风格产生了重大影响。这非常类似于1962年对主流美国的想象，所有的成年人都穿着西装、抽着香烟、喝着烈酒。恶魔是卡通化的，而人物是写实的、直接绘制的。正是这种张力使连环画得以运作。卡通化的地狱走卒与极其直截了当的主流之间的对抗。我认为，特别是对于恶魔噩梦来说。《恶魔的噩梦》是杰克·奇克所谓的“灵魂赢取小册子”中的第一本。
comics had a big influence on Jack's visual style. It's very kind of 1962 vision of mainstream America, where all the adults are wearing suits and smoking cigarettes and drinking hard drinks. The demons are cartoony and the people are realistic and drawn straight. That's the tension that makes the comic strip work. Is the cartoony hell's minions versus the very straightforward mainstream? I think especially with the demons nightmare. A demons nightmare was the first of what Jack Chick called his soul-winning tracks.
这些书旨在基督教书店购买并分发，以引导非信徒信仰宗教。它还具有使漫画成为漫画的那种怪异感，这是杰克在未来几十年里会反复使用的套路。魔鬼是小妖精。他们是可爱、神经质的小恶魔，有着夸张的面部表情。
Books meant to be purchased at Christian bookstores and handed out to bring non-believers into the faith. It also has the kind of weirdness that make comics, comics, tropes that Jack would use over and over again for the next several decades. The devils are imp. They are little cute, neurotic little demons with exaggerated facial expressions.
当他们感到紧张时，汗珠会从头上跳出来或顺着脸颊流淌。邪恶的小妖精乘坐特快电梯在幽深的地狱和城市街道之间往返。一个恶魔拉着小提琴，用摇篮曲向一个无辜的青少年唱着小夜曲。如果你不读文字，你甚至可能会误以为它只是一部普通的漫画。他非常善于利用幽默漫画小册子的概念，将你引入他关于硫磺火湖和永远沉沦的信息中，这种效果对读者的冲击力非常强烈。杰克为《恶魔的噩梦》绘制的封面成为了他漫画的模板。
And when they get nervous, drops of sweat jump under their head or run down their face. The evil imbs ride an express elevator back and forth between the bowels of hell and the city streets. One demon plays the violin while serenading an innocent teenager with a lullaby. If you didn't read the text, you might even mistake it for just a regular comic. He was very much using the idea of a comic, funny booklet to hook you into his fire and
它的一半是双色插图，另一半是粗体白字的小册子标题。这种优雅、瞬间可辨的分割封面设计成为了几乎所有小册子的标准外观。不过，如果没有这一个小小的调整，杰克的漫画可能永远不会走向全球，
brimstone, eternal damnation message, and the effect is really strong on the reader. And the cover that Jack drew for a demon's nightmare became a template for his comics. It features a two-color illustration on one half and the track title in bold white letters on the other half. This elegant, instantly recognizable, split-cover design became the standard look for almost all chick tracks. It's possible though that Jack's tracks would have never gone global,
也永远不会进入我们公共空间的每个角落和缝隙。我们将在休息之后讨论那是什么。1969年，杰克·奇克一直用来制作小册子的印刷厂老板正在修改他的工艺，以满足其他订单。再次请出杰克的传记作家大卫·尼尔斯。他去找杰克说：“我们不能再印刷这种大开本的东西了。你觉得你能把它缩印以继续使用同一台印刷机吗？”杰克需要将他的小册子缩小一半以上，从经典的漫画书尺寸缩小到不到三乘五英寸。
that they'd never have found their way into every nook and cranny of our public space if it weren't for just one little tweak. And we'll get into what that is after the break. In 1969, the print shop owner that Jack Chick had been using to make his tracks was modifying his process to fill some other orders. Here's Jack's biographer, David Daniels again. And he went to Jack and said, we're not going to be able to print these big format things anymore. Do you think you could shrink it down to keep using the same printer? Jack needed to cut his tracks by more than half from classic comic book size down to a little under three by five inches.
杰克说：“没问题。”于是他把较长的小册子改短，把插图缩小，需要的话进行修改，重画了一些插图等等，但实际上这太棒了，因为它现在可以放进口袋里了。杰克决定将漫画书缩减为袖珍小册子，这帮助小册子走向了世界。他开创了一个成功的公式：将引人注目的宣传漫画艺术与圣经经文和福音派信息结合起来。然后，他将这一切缩小成这些微小的病毒式传播包裹，几乎就像小志一样。重新排版的漫画是传教的完美工具。你知道，我认为福音派有一个秘密，
Jack said, sure. And so he took the longer tracks and made them shorter and he shrunk the art down, modified it if he needed to, redid some of the art and stuff, but it actually made it wonderful because it fits in the pocket now. Jack's decision to cut his comic books down to pocket-sized booklets helped launch chick tracks out into the world. He pioneered a successful formula by mashing up grabby propaganda comic art with Bible verses and evangelical messaging. And then he took all of that and shrank it down into these little viral packages, almost like little zines. And the newly reformatted comics were perfect tools for proselytizing. You know, I think there's a secret about evangelicals,
那就是很多人发现传教很难。梅兰妮·麦卡利斯特教授美国研究，她写过一本关于福音派的书。对于大多数人来说，与朋友或陌生人交谈并不是一件容易的事，无法轻易说出“这就是我所相信的，这就是我认为你应该相信的”。这对很多人来说都很困难。向完全陌生的人传教是福音派的基本部分。
which is that a lot of people find it hard to evangelize. Melanie McCallister teaches American studies and she wrote a book about evangelicals. It's not an easy thing for most people to talk to friends or strangers and say, this is what I believe, this is what I think you should believe. It's difficult for a lot of people. Prostletizing to complete strangers was a fundamental part of evangelicalism.
他们称之为“见证”。但是，如果你那敬畏上帝的心无法抵御严重的社交焦虑呢？这些小漫画对害羞的基督徒来说太棒了。正如杰克·奇克漫画中的一个角色曾经说过的那样：见证不一定非得那么可怕。“小册子”让这一切变得很简单。就像这样，我要给你看这个东西。这不完全是我在跟你说话。
They call it witnessing. But what if your God-fearing heart was no match for your crippling social anxiety? These little comics were great for shy Christians. As a Jack Chick comic character once said, witnessing doesn't have to be terrifying. Chick tracks make it easy. Like here, I'm going to show you this thing. It's not exactly me talking to you.
我是在向你展示这个东西，并向你讲述这个我们可以一起阅读的东西。对于杰克来说，推出他全新改进的福音漫画的时机再好不过了。杰克在1969年的重新设计恰逢基督教世界发生的一些重大变化。这些变化将使“小册子”的需求量大增。首先，美国福音派正在成为全球宣教工作的领导者，许多人
I'm showing you this thing and telling you about this thing that we can read together. The timing couldn't have been better for Jack to drop his new and improved gospel comics. Jack's redesign in 1969 coincided with some big changes that were happening in the Christian world. Changes that would help put chick tracks in serious demand. First, American evangelicals were becoming leaders in global missionary work, and many
将“小册子”视为海外见证的重要工具。其次，在20世纪70年代这一时期，福音派和其他所有人一样，对他们所做事情的反文化氛围产生了更浓厚的兴趣。因此，他们希望事物具有相关性，易于获取，相关，易于获取，用户友好。这是一个反抗和各种实验的时期，许多福音派认为拯救灵魂的方法是用这种反文化氛围的吸引力来诱惑他们。
saw chick tracks as vital tools for witnessing abroad. And second, in the period of the 1970s, evangelicals like everybody else become more interested in a kind of countercultural feel to the things that they're doing. And so they want things to be relevant, to be accessible, to be relevant, to be accessible, to be user-friendly. This was a period of resistance and all kinds of experimentation, and lots of evangelicals thought that the way to save souls was to lure them in with an appeal to this countercultural vibe.
留着长发的嬉皮士传教士、为耶稣子民举办的巨大伍德斯托克式音乐节以及基督教摇滚，所有这一切都是这场福音派革命带给你的。当传教士试图与年轻人建立联系时，他们中的许多人会掏出杰克的小基督教漫画，这些漫画至少看起来具有与时代同频的开放性和前卫感。因此，像杰克·奇克这样提供易于消化、用户友好、进入信仰的短小入口的人，就变得合理了。而在20世纪60年代初，这种方式是行不通的。
The long-haired hippie preachers, the huge woodstock-type festivals for Jesus' people, and Christian rock, all of it brought to you by this evangelical revolution. As preachers try to connect with the youth, many of them would whip out Jack's little Christian comic books, which at least seem to have an openness and edginess that were in sync with the times. And so people like Jack Chick who are offering easily digestible user friendly short entrees into the faith, they make sense. And the way they just wouldn't have made sense in the early 1960s.
杰克的漫画订单雪片般飞来。生意如此火爆，以至于杰克不得不把他的公司从车库搬到了波莫纳的一个工业套房里。奇克出版公司真的起飞了。他们买了自己的印刷机。他们拥有了自己的分销网络。他们把所有的东西都推向了市场。他们在赚钱。接下来，为了吸引更广泛、更年轻的受众，杰克决定聘请一位更现代、技术更娴熟的插画家，名叫弗雷德·卡特。杰克需要弗雷德来接触年轻一代，他们已经习惯了他们在漫威漫画等中长大的那种更有肌肉感的动作
Orders for Jack's tracks came pouring in. Business was so hot that Jack had to move his company from his garage to an industrial suite in Pomona. Chick publications is really taking off. They've bought their own printer. They've got their distribution networks. They're getting everything out there. They're making money. Next, in order to appeal to a wider and younger audience, Jack decided to hire a more modern and more skillful illustrator named Fred Carter. Jack needed Fred to reach the younger generation who were accustomed to more muscular action
漫画。而这正是弗雷德可以填补的空白。杰克永远做不到这一点，因为杰克的风格是一种根植于连环画时代的卡通风格。到70年代末，杰克公司已经售出了超过1亿册“小册子”。有一个古老的奇克出版公司标志，展示了被“小册子”环绕得像土星一样的地球。
comics that they'd grown up with in Marvel Comics, etc. And that's the niche that Fred could fill. The Jack never could because Jack's tile was a cartoony style that was still rooted in the newspaper strip era. By the late 70s, Jack's company had pushed more than 100 million chick tracks out the door. There's an old chick publications logo that shows the planet earth encircled like Saturn by a ring of chick tracks.
这并不算夸张。自杰克创办奇克出版公司以来的几十年里，他那便宜、非常炫酷的袖珍漫画获得了通常只有畅销书和日报才能享有的知名度。也许名气更大。几年前，该公司售出了它的第十亿册小册子。很多人会说：“好吧，这挺令人印象深刻的。这是他出版的数量，但这并不是被阅读的数量，因为平均一本小册子会经手许多人。”他们读完后，就会把它传给别人，因为，你知道，嘿，我读完了。他们会这样做大约10次左右。因此，他的受众范围要比
And it's not really an exaggeration. In the decades since Jack started chick publications, his cheap, very cool looking pocket-sized comics reached a type of popularity that's otherwise reserved for best-selling novels and the daily paper. Maybe bigger. A couple of years ago, the company sold its one billionth tract. A lot of people say, okay, well, that's pretty impressive. That's how many he publish, but that's not how many that have been read, because the average chick track goes through many people's hands. They read them, and then they pass them on to somebody else, because, you know, hey, I'm done reading it. And they'll do that 10 times or so. So his reach is much more broad
普通书虫广泛得多。奇克出版公司至今依然强劲发展，即使没有了其同名创始人。杰克于2016年去世，享年92岁。直到今天，他的公司仍收到大量来自宣教士的订单。福音派人士仍然参与一项被称为“传单轰炸”的悠久实践，他们有时在夜间蜂拥至你的街区，用数百本小册子淹没汽车挡风玻璃、门把手、邮箱以及你的前门下方。
than your average book reader. Chick publications is still going strong today, even without its eponymous leader. Jack died in 2016 when he was 92 years old. To this day, his company gets tons of orders from missionaries. Even Jellicle still participate in a time-honored practice that they call tract bombing, where they swarm your neighborhood sometimes at night and flood it with hundreds of booklets on windshields and door knobs in mailboxes and under your front door.
当你醒来时，仿佛“小册子”像十灾之一一样从天而降。我采访了几位深入思考过杰克·奇克作品的人，他们大多数都极其厌恶他的信息。毕竟，“小册子”一直是病毒式仇恨的无可否认且无法遏制的源头。多年来，杰克的关注点从普遍的道德沦丧转变为关于同性恋以及几乎所有非新教宗教的更丑陋、更详细的故事。但对于许多人来说，这位艺术家和他的古怪小漫画仍然有某种有趣
And when you wake up, it's as if chick tracts have rained down down like one of the 10 plagues. I talk to several people who have thought a lot about Jack Chick's work, and most of them absolutely detest his messages. After all, chick tracks have been an undeniable, uncontainable source of viral hate. Over the years, Jack's focus intensified from general moral decay to much uglier and more detailed yarns about homosexuality and pretty much all non-protestant religions. But there's still something about the artist and his weird little comic books that's interesting
甚至诱人的地方。当我长大的时候，你在万圣节会收到它们，你会发现它们散落在镇子的各处。我曾是一名送报童，我在那里发现了很多“小册子”。当丹·雷伯恩在20世纪70年代和80年代还是爱荷华城的一个孩子时，他正是按照杰克·奇克预期的那样，到处都能遇到“小册子”。在我小学门前，你知道，在学年开始的时候，有人会在那里给孩子们留下厚厚一叠“小册子”，我们都会去抢。但丹作为大学生并没有像杰克希望的那样到处散发它们，而是做了许多
and even a luring from many of those folks. When I was growing up, you'd get them on Halloween, you would find them scattered across town. I was a paper boy and I would find a lot of chick tracks there. When Dan Rayburn was a kid in Iowa City in the 1970s and 80s, he came across chick tracks just the way Jack Chick intended, everywhere. In front of my elementary school, you know, at the beginning of the year, somebody would leave a little pile of chick tracks there for the kids, and we would all grab them. But instead of spreading them around the way Jack wanted, as a college kid Dan did what many
甚至能吸引到其中许多人。当我长大的时候，你在万圣节会收到它们，你会发现它们散落在镇上。我曾是个送报童，我在那里发现了很多奇克小册子。当丹·雷伯恩（Dan Rayburn）在20世纪70年代和80年代还是爱荷华城的一个孩子时，他就像杰克·奇克（Jack Chick）所希望的那样，到处都能遇到奇克小册子。在我小学门前，你知道的，在学年开始的时候，有人会在那里给孩子们留下厚厚一小叠奇克小册子，我们都会去抢。但丹在大学时并没有像杰克希望的那样把它们到处散发，而是做了许多
collectors have done, he just hoarded them away for himself. You know, my roommates and I would kind of laugh about them and you keep them on the on the little tray next to your, you know, your rolling papers and your copy of Led Zeppelin 2, they'd kind of migrate to the top of the toilet and people would read them while they used the bathroom and they'd just sort of disintegrate and fall apart. None of those chick tracks ever converted Dan, but he did become an avid chick track reader. He couldn't help it. The comics just seems so over the top. In the last few decades, Jack has found a pretty big audience with people like Dan.
收藏家做的那样，他只是把它们囤积起来留给自己。你知道的，我和室友们有时会拿它们开玩笑，你把它们放在小托盘上，就在你卷烟纸和《齐柏林飞艇2》专辑的旁边，它们不知怎么就会移到马桶盖上，人们在洗手间的时候就会读它们，然后它们就会不知不觉地解体、碎掉。那些福音小册子从来没有真正感化过丹，但他确实成了一个狂热的福音小册子读者。他忍不住。这些漫画看起来实在太夸张了。在过去几十年里，杰克通过像丹这样的人吸引了相当多的受众。
Folks who are actually sucked in and even tickled by the horrifying and self-righteous everything phobia of chick tracks. On fan sites, collectors have videos where they lean fully into the weirdness of chick's comics. Oh, hi, friends. Preacher here. Hey, friends, today I want to invite you
那些真正被福音小册子中那种充满恐惧、自以为是又无所不包的偏执所吸引，甚至感到好笑的人。在粉丝网站上，收藏家们发布的视频里，他们完全沉浸在杰克漫画的怪异之中。哦，嗨，朋友们。牧师在此。嘿，朋友们，今天我想邀请你们
to become a member of the Chick-Track Club. Now, you know those. Those are the old comic booklets that put the fun back in fundamentalism. Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha,odies of themselves. Hilarious precisely because they're such earnest, paranoid relics. Others see parallels between chick tracks and early DIY zine culture. Here's Jason Bivens again. You know, chick was punk as fuck. He controlled his own distribution. It's almost like staple gunning advertisements for your show or leaving free copies of your
成为福音小册子俱乐部的一员。现在，你们都知道那些。那些是把乐趣重新带回原教旨主义的旧漫画小册子。……它们简直成了自身的滑稽模仿。之所以搞笑，恰恰是因为它们是如此一本正经、偏执狂热的遗物。其他人则看到了福音小册子与早期DIY杂志文化之间的相似之处。再次听听杰森·比文斯的看法。你知道的，杰克朋克得要命。他控制着自己的发行渠道。这几乎就像是用订书机把你的演出广告钉起来，或者把你的免费副本留在
fanzine on the front, you know, on the canter of the record store. It's a similar kind of mentality. Get the word out, repeat the message, and hopefully effect change that way. Jack Chick has been called a lot of things in the press over the last 60 years. Alunatic Jesus Freak, a comic scareremonger, a fire-breathing, Helen Brimstone preacher, and an underground cartooning genius. His tracks are just as complicated, shocking, graphic, hateful, and just plain mean. And for better or for worse, completely unique. It's what drew readers to chick tracks
前台，你知道的，留在唱片店的柜台上。这是一种类似的心态。把消息传出去，重复这个信息，并希望能以此带来改变。在过去的60年里，媒体给杰克·奇克贴上了各种各样的标签。一个疯狂的耶稣狂热分子、一个散布恐惧的漫画贩子、一个喷火吐硫磺的传教士，以及一个地下漫画天才。他的小册子同样复杂、震撼、生动、充满仇恨，而且直白得恶毒。无论好坏，它们都是独一无二的。正是这一点吸引着读者去阅读福音小册子
from the very beginning. 99% of the visible was produced this week by Christopher Johnson, edited by Kelly Prime, sound mix and a digital production by Martin Gonzales, music by director San Swan Rihau. Satan is real, was written by the Louven Brothers, this version performed here by the Grace Thrillers. Delaney Hall is our senior editor, Kurt Colestad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Perrubé, Jason Dillion, and Mithit Sheld, Vivian Le, Lashamadon, Jacob Maldonana Medina, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are a part of the Stitcher & Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks
本期《99%无形》由克里斯托弗·约翰逊制作，凯利·普莱姆剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯负责混音和数字制作，音乐由导演山姆·斯旺·里豪创作。《撒旦是真实的》由卢万兄弟创作，此处由格蕾丝·惊悚乐队演唱。德兰尼·霍尔是我们的资深编辑，库尔特·科莱斯塔德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁贝、杰森·迪利安、米蒂特·谢尔德、薇薇安·勒、拉沙马顿、雅各布·马尔多纳纳·梅迪纳、乔·罗森伯格，以及我——罗曼·马尔斯。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher & Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区
north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Reddit and TikTok too. You can find links to other you. Saytime is real. Working is weird. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区的漂亮地段。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上@我（Roman Mars）以及节目账号（99PI org）。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以找到其他内容的链接。萨坦是真实的。工作很诡异。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。